Things are a little trickier than this,
however.
It is occasionally necessary, even when
modeling external visible behavior of
a device, to invent some
additional internal states.
The most common example are timers,
such as what we saw earlier.
A user can't really understand
how a clock radio works
without appreciating that there
are several internal timers working.
See if you can come up with a list
of what internal timers are there.
Okay, what timers do you have?
>> So,
the first one is the snooze timer.
So as soon as you hit the snooze button,
then in 10 minutes,
the-
>> Times up to 10 minutes, sure.
What else?
>> There is an alarm time.
I think, or you know,
the alarms not going to go on forever.
So there's like an internal, isn’t there
a state for, our alarm has started and
then at some point the alarm needs to
go off so its not playing forever.
>> So, recall the original requirements
in which we said that the alarm can only
go for an hour, and so there has to be
a timer to time up to that one hour.
>> Okay.
What else?
>> For the sleep, internally
when you are playing music and
you have your sleep timer set.
Is there something that kicks off?
Usually you press sleep on,
right, or something like that?
And then it'll run until it meets
the time you set for when the-
>> Well if you set the sleep timer.
Then when you move your slide switch or
mode switch into radio or
alarm, I guess into radio,
it's going to, normally if you hadn't
set the sleep time, it would go off.
You wouldn't be hearing any radio.
So, if you're sitting there and
move it to on, radio comes on.
>> Okay.
>> But if you move it to radio.
>> Music
>> Music, music.
Okay, it would normally go off.
But if you have the sleep timer set,
it goes off after that amount of time.
>> And then, another internal
timer is for your sleep timer.
I guess I want to make sure I understand
correctly how the sleep timer,
like how it functionally works.
So you press the sleep time, and
that's like, say you want to play for
30 minutes before it goes off.
So to activate that, what mode do you
need to be in to start your sleep timer?
>> Okay, so
there's two things going on here.
Setting the amount of time
before the radio goes off and
then actually causing that to happen at
night when you're ready to go to sleep.
So, we know how to set the time
by hitting the sleep button and
then setting some time there.
Now, it turns out on this
particular clock radio,
we've seen that the possibilities
are 12 hours and there's 60 minutes.
But, this particular clock radio,
you can only set it for,
I believe, up to an hour.
>> Okay.
>> So, you're really just
setting the minutes part of it.
And, I haven't personally tried
this feature out, so I don't
what the internal logic does in the
situation where you say three hours and
twenty minutes, even though it only
can do this sleeping for an hour.
So, that's one thing that as an actual
developer, we'd have to decide upon.
>> Okay.
>> Then there's the question of how,
when you're going to bed at night,
this thing works, and what it is,
is if you have set the sleep time,
if it's got an actual value
you've put in there,
when you move the mode switch into
radio you would normally
expect not to hear anything.
But if you've got the sleep time
set then you would actually expect
the radio to continue playing
until that sleep time expires.
>> Okay.
So then, I guess,
just the internal timer for that.
So as soon as you move
it into that mode,
it goes up until you're
to that threshold.
>> Right.
>> And then lastly,
we have this internal clock timer for
your actual display clock.
>> So yeah, we're clocking
the minutes and hours as they go by,
and so there has to be some timer
to do that particular thing.
So we can add these timers and
sub-machines,
and when we do the results,
this is what you see here.